[Music]
in ancient times humans studied the
night sky and discovered the worlds of
Mercury Venus Mars Jupiter and Saturn
but beyond this realm of knowledge
another world shined brightly
just waiting to be discovered Uranus is
the seventh planet from the Sun from a
distance of about 20 astronomical units
for 20 times the distance between Earth
and the Sun Uranus orbits the star once
every 84 earth years approximately the
length of a human's entire life this
orbit causes each season of Uranus to
last that much longer theoretically a
human living on Uranus would experience
the four seasons
only once but each for about 21 years
partially due to its distance from the
Sun Uranus boasts the coldest
temperatures in the solar system these
icy temperatures dropping as low as
negative 370 degrees Fahrenheit are
largely influenced by the planet's
composition at about 4 Earth's wide
Uranus has an earth-sized core made of
iron and magnesium silicate the
remainder approximately 80% of Uranus is
a worldwide ocean of ices made of water
ammonia and methane the chemical behind
the planets cooled blue color this icy
composition prevents Uranus from
emitting much heat compared to other
planets making the blue world the solar
system's coldest
in addition to its extreme temperatures
at orbit Uranus has a dramatic
orientation while the other seven
planets spin on their axes like tops
Uranus appears to roll along its equator
the planet is tilted at a near right
angle in which polar regions point
toward and away from the Sun rather than
upward and downward this tilt thought to
be the result of Uranus is collision
with at least one celestial body has
also affected the orientation of
Uranus's thirteen rings and 27 known
moons
unlike the rings and moons of other
worlds which orbit their home planets
horizontally those of Uranus orbit in a
vertical orientation along the planets
tilted equator much like a ferris wheel
Uranus and its many unusual features
were a mystery to the ancients and the
planet was actually thought to be a star
but in the late 18th century astronomer
William Herschel discovered that the
celestial object was actually a new
world the scientific community debated
over what the planet should be called
and eventually chose a name suggested by
astronomer Johann alert bowed bowed
believed that since Jupiter was the
father of the gods and Saturn was the
father of Jupiter then this new planet
should be the father of Saturn C Lewis
but rather than following the tradition
of using names from ancient Roman
religion bowed instead opted for C Lucis
ancient Greek equivalent who knows who
knows the ancient Greek god of the
heavens was then latinized to be Uranus
to this day Uranus is still the only
planet that veered from tradition with
an ancient Greek namesake a status most
fitting for a planet beyond convention
[Music]